are you getting the hang of the
parenting thing do you are you good or
you have good instincts as a parent I'm
really enjoying it
I've started playing a really great
long-form joke on him okay let's hear
this just you don't have cable so she
won't see ya okay I said we he's not so
involved in the joke right
he's 15 weeks old yes so when I like I
bring him to the park in the morning and
sometimes would be there would be like a
family having a picnic or whatever
you're just hanging out and I so I give
him to the family and I take a picture
right above the strange family holding
him holding him yeah and my idea is that
I'm gonna get the photos developed and
I've started putting like weird I kind
of did gypsy scarves and stuff on him
and I'm gonna get the photos developed
and I'm gonna put them in a frame behind
another picture and when he's around 14
or 15 I got a tower you know he'll be
like oh I need a frame and I'm like and
then he'll pull out the photo and he'll
take that he belong to another fabulous
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
start looking at he'll start looking at
all the pictures you're not clear and
he'll be like there's tons of them and
I'm gonna get it like so when he comes
downstairs with the photo on he's like
who's that why am i with these people
I'm like what did you get